yeah I can talk about the red pill I can  complain about it just too I think there  is I I to be fair  um I do think there is a lot of angry  bitter men which are attracted to it uh  and those are the ones that will leave  these stupid comments my point was that  okay but my point is that's they're  they're already being punished by God  and by Society so don't worry about it  my point is that if a woman doesn't act  correctly she doesn't feel the true  sting of punishment not in her prime  years she may feel it later but in her  prime years it doesn't [ __ ] even  matter which is why they do it whereas  if a man doesn't have a [ __ ] in order  trust me he knows very well because his  realities sucks and that's why he's  sending you DMS because he's lonely